TIMOTHY JORDAN: So we're
going to be talking
about distributing
your Glassware.
We're going to talk
about two things.
One, what is the review process?
And then two, what's new?
And this part's going
to be pretty awesome.
And then at the end, I did
leave some time for Q&A.
So we can talk about that.
I am Timothy Jordan.
I'm a Developer Advocate
working on wearables at Google.
And that's Jeff Harris.
Jeff just found out
how to get here.
And Jeff is a Product
Manager for Platform on Glass
and he's going to be joining
me for Q&A at the end.
OK, so let's dive right in.
In the last six months, the
catalog of Glassware on MyGlass
has grown 80%, is
pretty [INAUDIBLE].
And in the last month alone,
we've launched more Glassware
then we have in
the previous five.
And it's not all the Glassware
that people are experimenting
with but rather these are
the ones designed and refined
against our best practices.
And there's even
[INAUDIBLE], in fact
there's a lot of Glass
wear in review today
that we know you're
going to love.
So let's just get right into it.
Why have a review
process at all?
Well, the reason
is simple but I'm
going to give you
some more detail.
We want to launch lots
of awesome Glasswear.
The lots is pretty
straightforward
but the awesome-- that
actually requires-- I mean,
that's the hard
part right there.
Now is a common goal
with App Stores.
Everybody wants to have
lots of great software
for the platform.
And there are all sorts
of review processes
and we took a look at these
before we designed our review
process.
You could have at one end of
the spectrum, no review at all.
Right?
Just let everything that comes
up, says "Hi," on to the store
and gets launched to the users.
On the rather end
of the spectrum,
you got this black box review.
Right?
You submit your
software for review
and you get a yes or a no
and you have no idea why.
Right?
Both these models exist out
there as for App Stores.
The Glassware
review process isn't
at either end of that spectrum.
In fact, you could
sort of say it's not
on that spectrum at all.
It's based on the idea
that we can help developers
create amazing
experiences on Glass.
And in fact, it'd be
crazy not to help them.
And it's also an opportunity
to understand more deeply what
you're doing in this early
phase of Glass and Glassware.
We learned from
the review process
and we use those learnings
to directly grow the platform
and product improvements.
Now, when the
Glassware comes in,
we look for two simple things.
First, is it safe for users?
Ultimately, there's
so much that we--
only so much that we can do.
But we can use the Glassware
and do our best to make sure,
at the very least, it
does what it says it does.
All right?
It asks for appropriate
permissions,
that kind of thing.
And this is sort
of obvious but we
should do what we
can in this area.
The next thing-- this is
the second out of the two,
is it these two things
are very different.
Right?
And in our experience working
with developers and partners
is that the tendency is to take
an experience from the phone
and just stamp it out on Glass.
It's the same
experience over there.
But the thing is, is
the paradigms on Glass
and how the user interacts with
it are remarkably different.
Right?
It's important for-- I'm
sorry, somebody's give me
hand motions.
And I don't know what-- OK.
You got to think about
what's special, right?
What can you do now that
you couldn't do before?
And then you had to do that.
And the review process is
there to help with that.
Right?
It's our goal never to say,
"No you can't do that."
Instead, any time
where it's like, "This
is something new or this is
outside the best practices."
How could we say to the
developer "yes and."
It's this beautiful concept
that we learned from improv,
where you build upon
each other's ideas.
Instead of saying
no to developers,
we help them adapt their ideas
and their dreams for user
and activity to this
new environment.
That make sense?
OK.
Here are the steps involved.
First, you submit
your Glassware.
There's a form.
You fill it out.
No big deal.
Then we have a conversation
and we offer assistance.
All right?
And this is the fun part.
This is where you get
the personal attention
of a Glassware expert and
sometimes the UX team itself
when there's new
things going on to help
you make the best
Glassware possible.
And then we get it
launched out to users.
That's the process.
All right, I'm going to come
back to that in a moment.
Here's a few new things
that we can talk about.
First off, we're always trying
to improve this process, right?
How can we make it
better for developers?
How can we make it faster?
How can we make it
where we're reliable?
How can we make all this
Glassware more awesome?
One of the things
that we silently
launched just a
couple months ago
is that you can now submit
both Mirror API Glassware
and GDK Glassware and
MyGlass will support both.
Now, some folks have gone
through this process,
as we just sort of
silently launched it.
Others are coming along.
And of course, we're
ready for more.
The next thing, another
sort of small announcement,
is that we've got a form
for updating your Glassware.
So if you've got
major changes and you
want us to look
at them, you'll be
able to see this form
on our documentation
in the next few days.
SPEAKER: --send advices.
You can--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: --have already
gone through the review process
and you just need
a quota increase,
you can use this form
for that as well.
OK.
Now finally a piece of feedback
we've gotten quite frequently
is that the review
process takes too long.
Well, we agree.
We would like to go faster.
And we examined it.
The one place where
everybody sort of
agrees that it is
taking too long
is between submitting
and getting
that first round of feedback.
And the way we
handle this, as you
saw in this diagram
earlier, is that we assemble
a whole list of
feedback and then we
give that as one chunk
back to the developer.
But then what happens
is that if there's
any big things they change,
we take a look at it,
and we have this conversation
about how to really make
this Glassware great
and fit onto Glass.
Well, since we're having
this conversation anyway,
why don't we just start that
conversation right away?
So we're announcing that we're
going to do earlier feedback.
Now what this means
is that as soon
as you submit your
Glassware, we're
going to start reviewing it
and as the feedback comes in,
we'll share that sheet with you
and you can see it as it comes.
So instead of waiting for
the full chunk, right?
As there's major pieces of
feedback that we give you,
you can start working
on those right away.
OK.
Another way that we're going to
help you get earlier feedback
and speed up the whole
process requires a new tool.
So I'd like to talk about that.
Now many of you might
have seen that there's
this common visual
language that I
use in a lot of my
presentations, right?
It's this representation
of the Glassware flow.
A tap goes down
on this flow chart
and a swipe forward
goes to the right.
A swipe back goes to the back.
And with this, it's a
pretty simple and effective
representation of how the
UI or the user experience
is on this Glassware.
Now I do this in Keynote
and it takes me awhile
to get this all right.
Where we've built
a tool and it's
going to be available to
you very soon in beta,
on the documentation site.
It's called the
Glassware Flow Designer.
Now the cool thing about this is
that you can just jump right in
and you can put in
HTML or screenshots
and then very quickly, build
this flow chart about how
your Glassware works, and it
saves all the files to Google
Drive so you can just share
them like you do any other files
to everybody you're
working with.
And you can collaboratively
edit this together.
Now our hope is
what you're going
to do is you're going to
build these right away,
even before you
start developing.
Right?
As you're thinking
about this idea.
And that you're going
to send this our way.
So we can take a
look at it, even
before you started
building things.
And we can give you those
major pieces of feedback
that we often like delivered
to people who submit Glassware
for the first time, even
before you start building,
to make the whole
process easier,
to make it even faster
from idea to launch,
not just submission
to review to launch.
So that's the new
things that we're doing.
You like that.
That's good.
Reviewing Mirror and GDK
Glassware available on MyGlass
now and anybody can
submit both of those.
Earlier feedback, we're going
to give you the feedback
as soon as it starts happening.
We've launched this Glassware
Flow Designer which is really
going to help you design your
Glassware and collaboratively
design that Glassware very
early on, even before you start
developing.
And that you'll be able to send
this our way so we can give you
that expert feedback
even before you've
started going down a path.
Now a very common
piece of feedback
is that sometimes people
use an immersion when
they should really
use a live card.
That's the kind
of thing you want
to know before you
build the immersion.
So we really want
to help with that.
And our resources are on
developers.google.com/glass/distribute.
I hope that you'll join us
there and ask questions.
If you add a /glass/community,
you can reach any of us and we
can talk about it
there, as well.
OK and with that, I'd like
to bring Jeff up on stage
and we're going to do some
questions and answers.
I have another microphone.
In fact, can I get
somebody to help?
Would you mind?
Thank you, Hoi.
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
One tool that I use on
the Play Store a lot,
both within my own team
and with the testing
apps with the broader user base
is the Beta and Alpha Channels.
Have you thought about
bringing anything
like that to the Glass store?
JEFF HARRIS: Uh, yes.
So we have some capabilities
like that already.
If you submit Glassware to us,
we can whitelist that Glassware
for just a Google group or
an individual set of users.
And we're pretty
willing to do that.
AUDIENCE: OK.
That's great.
Just so one other question.
What's sort of a crash reporting
tool or aggregated stats
do you currently offer
through the MyGlass store?
Like for the developer side?
JEFF HARRIS: So our UI stuff
for that isn't that great.
We do tend to communicate
to developers when
we see the crash report.
So if we see your
app crashing a lot,
we will reach out
and let you know.
But there isn't a
proactive way for you
to get that information.
AUDIENCE: So do you recommend
that we use other tools
like a crash analytics or
maybe other third parties
to collect stats if
there's not like a tool--
JEFF HARRIS: I think that's
generally a good idea.
AUDIENCE: OK.
All right.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi, my
name is [INAUDIBLE].
This question is related
to the-- can you hear me?
JEFF HARRIS: Yes.
AUDIENCE: This
question is related
to do-- like the
hardware part of this.
Nothing, my major seriously.
But can you find a mechanism,
do a simple thing to this Glass
and let people know when
you will go to a restaurant
or somewhere that
this camera is not on.
Because I hate to remove
it when people like,
"You need to move that."
So as a mechanism,
just to put it in,
people can see that this,
the camera part is closed
and it's not going to record.
Still I can review
my emails, like check
who's sending me a message on.
So it's just like something
like a universally
accepting, "OK, the
camera is covered."
So don't worry.
You don't have remove that
at a restaurant or a bar,
pub, or even when you
walk to the restaurants.
Sometimes, I accidentally
walk, oh, I have to go back.
So that-- can you do that?
It's-- I don't think it's
a major hard problem.
But I think it's
just a suggestion,
it will be helpful to everyone.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Thank you.
So just for the people that
might not have heard that,
it's a feature request.
Definitely appreciate that.
We sort, of course, can't
comment on any future features
or where we may go in that area.
But if you do have
feature requests,
definitely welcome them.
Next question.
AUDIENCE: So one of the things
I was really excited about when
you said [INAUDIBLE] it was--
Mirror, GDK combined apps.
And I know one of
the things you add
was the authentication flow,
where you could have a Mirror
app that then authenticates
the GDK by creating
an account on Glass.
And I know, right
now the requirement
is you gotta need to submit
before you can try any
of the accounts stuff on advice?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah.
So this is how that works.
And there are some
challenges in here.
And I think we could provide
some more tooling over time.
But if you want now to
have a GDK Glassware that
has an account and
authentication, therefore,
you don't we don't to
use the Mirror API.
But there is a
RESTful API that you
hit where you send the
account information to Google
and then when the APKs delivered
to Glass through MyGlass,
the account is as well so it's
available to your application
when it starts up.
The sort of shim
that you can use now
is you can use ADB to send
this account to Glass yourself.
Right?
So you can test
all the components
of getting the user
up to the point where
you would send the account
information to Google
and then you have to plug the
device in and do ADB and send
the APK.
And then when you do bring your
Glassware through to the review
process, part of what
you'll get is the ability
to test that on MyGlass
before you launch.
Yeah.
But you will need that
shim up until that point.
AUDIENCE: You try to
never say "No, you
can't do that on Glass."
Have you actually flat
out rejected any apps?
Have you ever to say that?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Well, we do
have developer policies, right?
And remember, I talked
about user safety
but also, like you got to
comply with the developer
policies and the API
terms of service.
When we see something that
doesn't, we will say no.
Right?
An example of this--
what's a good example?
JEFF HARRIS: Like one example
is we don't let apps launch that
use the camera without
turning the screen on.
For kind of the concern
that you get at.
We want some visual indication
that the camera's running.
So we wouldn't let an app
launch if it didn't do that.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
But the-- where we
give the feedback is that
we'd say specifically that.
Like "yes, you
can use the camera
but you need to
have the screen on."
So it's adapting the idea
to the Glassware and Glass
world and the way
of doing things.
Question down here.
AUDIENCE: I submitted a
Glassware three weeks ago
and I'm still in the "too
long" part of you flow chart.
I was that thinking about--
what about giving a-- like,
because I assume
that you are looking
at two different things about
the app at the same time.
Like giving, like
more transparency say.
Because it's far as
simple, you can reject apps
or say there's a
problem with app
like from the very beginning.
For example, the
content is offensive
or why not say like "Your
app was approved for that
and now we are
checking this part.
We're checking--"
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
That's exactly what
we want to do with
the earlier feedback.
One of the-- we look at
a lot of the big things
that we can recognize quickly
that are often sort of done
wrong or that we can help with.
We give that feedback
as soon as possible.
There is some Glassware that
sort of in this place where
we had kind of a long
queue that hasn't
gotten that early feedback yet.
But we're working hard to
work through that backlog
and get that out as
soon as possible.
AUDIENCE: And same question--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And we're
also growing the team
and scaling up to
meet some more demand.
And it's interesting how
the Glassware submissions
have grown over time.
We also want to
grow the team to be
a bit more responsive to that.
AUDIENCE: And out curiosity, how
many Glassware submissions do
you receive?
Or is that--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: You know, I
don't have that number with me
today.
AUDIENCE: OK, thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hey, I have a
question about the standby mode.
In the-- before
XE18, I think, there
was no vision feedback
on the display.
So it was great
for saving battery.
I would put it on standby or
would take pictures and record
videos and saving battery.
And now with the
XE18, the display
turns on so I get a
feedback, which is great.
But then I lose battery faster.
What's up with that?
Is that something for the
privacy issue you mentioned?
JEFF HARRIS: I'm actually not
aware of that behavior change.
So standby mode, you mean
when you press the button
on the side of Glass?
So that should turn off the
display and you're saying it
doesn't?
AUDIENCE: Correct.
Yes.
So now it goes on standby
mode, so I cannot tap anymore.
But when I take a
picture, record a video,
the screen turns back on.
JEFF HARRIS: I see.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Every
time you take a picture,
record a video, the
screen should turn on,
whether you're in
standby mode or not.
AUDIENCE: Different question
about upgrading a Mirror
API to add additional
permissions.
So if you have a Glassware
that only does one permission
and you have
additional permissions,
for example, the authentication.
How does that user flow and
then also the development flow
work with adding
new permissions?
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
This is a challenge.
Jeff and I have talked
about this a lot, right?
Because you want
to give-- you want
to get permission
for those things
that you're doing with
your application that day.
And if you have
another permission
for some future
feature, like it's
weird to ask the user for that
even though you're not using it
right away.
You really want
just the permission
you're going to use
and then expand.
And this is OAuth problem as
much as it is anything else.
Is they whenever you
expand permission,
you need the user to go
through that flow again.
A way that you can
do this today is
that you can notify the
users in an appropriate way
and just have them go
through the flow again.
It could be as simple
as going to MyGlass
and turn it off
and on or could be
like clicking a link that
brings them to that flow
and they just re-accept
their permissions which
updates your token and then
you have those permissions.
There's probably more that
we could do here with MyGlass
and we're definitely
exploring options around that.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm going back to
the earlier question
of using the
authentication in GDK.
And you gave a solution.
Is there a way to find
all these solutions in
somewhere in the Help
or [INAUDIBLE] of GDK?
Like--
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Oh, yeah.
You mean like to
use the ADB shim
to get the account
on the device?
Tony, do you know if we
have documentation on that?
If not, we should probably
get some together.
I can make a post.
AUDIENCE: Next release.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: There is
the Android documentation
about this.
It's Account Manager
stuff, right?
And there is a way to use ADB to
get an account onto the Account
Manager.
Remember that Glass is built on
Android and whenever possible,
we do things in the
standard Android way.
All we're doing with
the GDK authentication
is when we deliver
the APK to the device,
we also deliver an
account that gets
added to the Account
Manager, based
on the credentials you gave
during the sign up process.
So all you're
doing with the shim
there is using ADB
to add that account.
AUDIENCE: But there
is the problem,
some of the GDK
features and all.
I can send you a list.
We are struggling
how to test this
without-- you know, before
we publish it and all.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Yeah, I mean
before you get into the review
process, you need
to test through ADB.
That's the right way to do it.
Once you get it in
the review process--
and Jeff was talking about how
we can whitelist the Glassware
for specific Google accounts or
a group or even a Google Apps
domain-- we can do that
pretty soon in the process.
So as soon as you
enter that process
and as you're
working on feedback,
you could also debug any
account issues that come up.
AUDIENCE: My next
question is, is there
any plan to support webview?
Or is there way to
support webview today?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: A plan
to support webview?
I'm looking at Tony and Jeff.
I don't know.
JEFF HARRIS: You can
use Chrome View today
like you can on Android, right?
Yeah.
That stuff should all
work just the same
as it does on regular Android.
AUDIENCE: So is there
anything special or should we?
JEFF HARRIS: I mean, the
interface won't look as good
if you look on most
websites because they're not
as optimized for a small screen
but it is the same rendering
engine so it should work
just the same in KitKat,
MR1 version, so--
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: At what
point should we
be submitting stuff for review?
When it's totally complete,
when it's feature complete,
when we've got a
really, really-- we're
really on the way and we're
ready to add authentication?
At what point do you
want to start seeing it?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So given
the announcements today,
this is the right
way to go about it--
is you use the Glassware
Flow Designer to create
a flow of how you
want the UI to work.
And this is part of
your design process.
Submit that before you start
developing and we'll give you
feedback on the overall,
like the big pieces
of the application, if there's
anything there to talk about.
Then you start developing.
The point at which you're
in near final testing,
you've got all your
big pieces in place,
and it looks the way
that you want it to,
and you start the
testing and debugging
phase, that's when
you want to submit it
to the Glassware review process.
And then we'll be part
of that process with you.
All right I think with time,
we'll take two more questions.
AUDIENCE: Just to say a
followup about updating APKs.
So is it correct
that the only way
to do that is by basically
resubmitting through that form?
That's not a way to
automatically add a new APK.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: So if
you're in the review process
and you've made changes
based on the feedback,
you'll have a line to the team
and you can send them APKs
through that, through
emails and other methods.
Once you've launch and
you have major features,
that's when you're going to
go to that update form that
will be live in the
next couple days.
AUDIENCE: All right.
And those updated
apps are automatically
pushed to users' devices?
Is that correct?
TIMOTHY JORDAN: Correct.
AUDIENCE:
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great.
Thanks.
TIMOTHY JORDAN:
One more question?
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So I submitted an app
to the Glassware gallery
about a month ago and I
haven't heard any feedback yet.
So what are-- what's
like the timeline
to kind of hear feedback?
JEFF HARRIS: A month,
unfortunately, is not atypical
right around now.
We've been kind of heads
down with getting stuff
ready for I/O, so I would expect
you should hear in less than a
month.
But in around a
month is probably
what most people have
been experiencing
over the past couple months.
So I would expect feedback soon.
If you tell me the app
afterwards, I can check, too.
TIMOTHY JORDAN: And, again,
because of the announcements
today, there's going
to be earlier feedback.
So our goal is to start getting
you feedback much earlier
than a month.
And hopefully
overall, the process
will take less time, as well.
So that's about
time for questions.
We'll be around for a
few minutes afterwards.
And if you have any questions
about your specific Glassware,
Jeff and I'll be around
for a little while.
Please do go to this URL,
engage with the documentation,
have a chat with us online.
It is our goal to make the
review process what developers
want it to be.
When we started building
this review process,
it was to help developers make
as awesome the Glassware they
can and to help
with that process.
It's still the goal.
We want to make it faster.
We want to make it more helpful.
We want to get really
awesome Glassware launched.
Thank you so much.
Thanks.